all righty old friend of the show and
he's got a new home Clay Matthews Rams
linebacker any similarities between
Green Bay and Los Angeles clay ah not
even in the slightest completely
different nothing that you know aside
from having a football team where
there's different peoples different just
overall different uh you know change of
scenery do you get recognized in Los
Angeles you know you played at USC but
do you stand out yeah I mean I was uh I
would get my physical when I first got
here signed with the Rams and the FedEx
guy in the elevator was you know using
expletives to that he saw me and just
wished me the best of luck so I felt
like you know I I still have some
recognizable power what was that like
that day when you were told or how I
don't know how you were told but the
Packers were moving on from you yeah I
mean it obviously was difficult I think
everybody envisions playing you know
their entire career out with one team
especially I having played a decade out
there but I was actually headed over
there to get a workout in because it was
a few days before hey agency they called
and let me know that it just wasn't in
the cards moving forward wish me the
best luck moving forward and we wrapped
up a 10-year career in about 30 seconds
own call but definitely caught us by
surprise but you know I immediately got
on the phone my agent
he was obviously privy to everything
that was going down as well and you know
obviously everybody says they want to
play for a contender but you know
especially as you just mentioned growing
up out here in Southern California going
to school with us and had lately you
know I think it would be a perfect fit
so fortunately uh coach berry and Wade
Phillips Joan beery they all started
reaching out to me and putting on a
full-court press as was I and able to
make something happen
but you give a team a decade and they
give you 30 seconds to wrap things up
clean out your locker I mean I know it's
a business but it it always felt like it
would be different in Green Bay am I you
know a romantic here and I'm thinking
I'm reading too much into it
no I mean it like I said everybody
envisions that but you know it's not
until you actually go through it you
realize you know how you know how rare
that is for one person to spend their
entire career I mean obviously everybody
brings a car and what he was able to do
in Green Bay and obviously moving on to
the Jets in Minnesota but yeah I mean
you know you look you look at the
direction of the team currently right
now with the new GM and with where
they're going obviously they made a
bunch of big moves in free agency
obviously you know making some trades
and letting some guys go that I've been
some you know some key figures over the
past several years I mean you can see
the direction in which you're going so I
is that for the better or worse that's
not for me to tell that I'm excited as a
part of the rest sure
did you call Aaron Rodgers did Rodgers
call you when you were let go well he
sent me a text yeah I was a little
disappointed when Geordi uh you know
when Geordi got let go he wrote you know
an emotional farewell and it's Instagram
when Randall they let him walk in free
agency he wrote an emotional farewell
but with me I just got attacked I was
you know because that's what Instagram
homeless you know just letting everyone
know how awesome their lifestyle is and
how much stuff he's doing
I mean all I got was a text and not an
Instagram post so I mean I got a bone to
pick with and week own in the offseason
you know I mentioned something about it
but he just couldn't find a time and
let's understand well after ten years it
was already hard to find the time to put
in a post oh yeah but he he wrote those
lovely letters because those guys were
receivers you're just a defensive player
that like you know he doesn't need the
receivers I think our relationship that
was forged with those State Farm
commercials is stronger than anybody's
authority - Randall on the are you gonna
do more commercials now that you're no
longer on the Packers is was that just
because you were on the Packers that you
got that opportunity with Aaron I think
it helped out I think you know you look
at what a harden was able to do with
Chris Paul in Houston but I mean what's
going to happen with that they already
film both because that's going to be
awkward you know if they start airing
though it's pretty soon it's going to be
Wes
appearing in those commercials now and
also naren's can having your best on
commercial no you know what happened
clay you and Chris Paul need to do a
commercial together yeah like if you've
been spurned people don't care about you
anymore
State Farm always cares about you I'm
gonna text Chris right now I'm gonna get
on and push it up the ladder
he's Clay Matthews the Rams line but it
still sounds strange to say that have
you have you said Packers at all like
have you made the mistake I have not but
and filling out paperwork it's always
just I want to pee but you know I
quickly erased that little line that
makes it you know they said a nard so I
just quickly adjust that what is your
role in the Rams team where's my role
well they got me playing outside
linebacker and a true you know three
four scheme late so it's defense it's
very similar to what I was doing through
the first probably nine years of my
career out there in Green Bay with Dom
Capers so I'm excited to be back working
in that role brushing the pasture
dropping into coverage you know playing
inside and running games on third down
so I you know I think they're using me
the same way that I've been used pretty
much for the entirety of my career I was
used a little differently last year with
you know the new defensive change that
we had out there in Green Bay but um I'm
excited about the using exactly how I
feel I should be used and you know I
think we're all on the same page yeah I
thought that was a football crime they
put you inside linebacker you know just
I know that for the good of the team but
I was thinking wow they're taking away
what you do well yeah I mean you know
you gotta be a team player and at the
same time you know it worked out you
know I was able to have some some
success playing inside and as a team as
well we had some success when I played
inside but you're right you don't you
know you can give a lot of premier pass
rushers and if asked to go inside I
doubt there's very many that are you
know raising their hand to go and do
that so you know I pride myself on being
able to do it all and you know what's
kind of fun and challenging to prove
myself to be able to play inside
you know play inside backer because it's
a different world but you know like I
said I had some success in there and now
forever in a pinch out here or you know
one of our I was back in Green Bay they
knew they could just tell me back inside
and it would be pretty seamless how is
the league changed since you first came
in the biggest change is what I would
say the biggest change and I know this
is probably whatever I'm going to say go
and say Oh better and player says is
that it is probably welcome coming on
you know I think for right or wrong you
know they need to be coached a different
way and I think that's why you see the
trend of a lot of these younger head
coaches coaches who you know
quote-unquote will be player friendly or
something along the lines I don't know
if they respond to so much of that
authoritarian type of coaching and I
think that's why you see you know
younger coaches guys who they can relate
to and feel like they're on the same
page you know and in this thing together
who's the best quarterback in the NFL
the continent in question that but you
know there's a lot of give me the
criteria where you wouldn't pick Aaron
Rodgers I mean everyone's gonna say
Super Bowls but I mean Thomas one isn't
you know you're gonna you know cruising
the press what he's been able to do you
just turn what city to the other day a
truly remarkable but yeah I mean as far
as something that lettuce is I'm
standpoint making every stroll and doing
it off one foot or you know just every
throw in the park you can't help but
think about Aaron and then you know
obviously with my auntie was able to do
last year you know I mean there's a
bunch there's a wealthy young talent
coming up so it's fun to watch her an
NFL fan I'm all these young quarterbacks
were having some level of success and at
the same time some of the old heads like
and Tom drew brees so whereas those guys
to continue to air it out and won't what
would you do if you don't play against
the Packers this year but what would you
tell the defense if you're facing Aaron
Rodgers
I don't know what I would tell them I
tell them you know good luck because
he's you know he's it's funny we were
watching now the inner part of Rams
watching the game in which we played
again from last year in the Coliseum and
you know sometimes there's just kind of
shrug the shoulders with what he's
capable of doing some of the fact that
he makes you know when he's in trouble
under pressure about to get south and he
just makes some wild throws who you know
covered receivers you come down and make
the play to play so I think the most
part you've got to stay after number you
know to really limit his playmaking
ability other than perhaps scheme or
having a guy like Aaron Donnell just you
know sack of every player do you think
you'll get in will you be one of the
groomsmen when he gets married to Danica
Patrick do you think are you gonna be in
the wedding maybe like the wink the ring
bear or something like that I don't know
I mean it could be pretty unconventional
but I hope so I mean I hope I hope it
doesn't get lost in the mail that could
happen and I'm thinking maybe we put the
rings in your ponytail and then you get
up there and then you shake your hair
out and then the rings come out and then
Chris all pops out you should become an
agent if this thing doesn't work out for
you I know oh yeah you know the sponsor
to endorse five mercedes banz which is
pretty incredible now right if it
doesn't work out for you being an agent
really oh well thank you it's one of the
nicest things you've ever said I think
clay I appreciate that
by the way how was your hair I know it
was in the middle of a play I was
running away and you know I kind of gave
you a little boost of confidence wait
wait do you shower before practice you
work alone what's going on oh yeah I
shower before practice yeah but I mean I
just you know with the level of
attention I pay to my hair
you know the haircare products I use you
know these with a nice floral smell
you know people recognize that sometimes
and I appreciate it yeah no that's you
should you should let it flow by the way
the best football player in the Matthews
family tree is who you know I mean
because obviously my uncle's in the Hall
of Fame you know I think my father's on
his way to joining the Hall of Fame
playing two different positions I think
my uncle was an absolute stud on the
offensive line you know played all five
positions including long snapper Pro
Bowl and everyone I'm sure I'll throw
pops played you know 19 years
I think he's third in the league in
tackles just a tremendous career when
you you know look at his stats and what
he's able to accomplish compared to some
of the best like you know junior say all
Mike Singletary guys like that so I
guess based on career I put them
together they both had 19 year careers
and you know both left the game is some
of the best but you know my cousin Jake
he's doing alright the ball last year
for the Falcons definitely on his way up
I think he just started his second
contract and obviously I've been I'm
long in the tooth as well so I'd give it
to my dad and uncle they had a pretty
tremendous career especially during that
day and age when you know guys guys
didn't play nineteen years well it's
good to talk to you glad you're doing
well probably took a while for the tears
to dry
did you cry when the Packers got rid of
you no I didn't cry come on you can tell
me no I didn't cry I mean am I supposed
to know people gonna look down upon me
because I didn't cry but if they bring
you back it'd be a better story but if
they bring you back and they honor you
like a one-day contract like let's say
five years down the road one day
contract come back with the Packers
tears I don't I don't think I don't
think maybe people cry on a one-day
contract well no you're being honored
like they do they have a Ring of Honor
there that they can do something they
have a ring there is a ring of honor
yeah I don't know I don't know what's
what's gonna happen down the road but I
don't know I mean I did I did watch I
did watch Coco the other day and I swear
I almost I almost teared up during that
Disney's Coco but I don't think so okay
as your agent you know nothing wrong
with tears man nothing wrong all right
all right nothing wrong I appreciate it
okay hey great talk to you I have fun
with the Rams and we appreciate your
time as always
that's Clay Matthews not jr. the third
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]